a huge manhunt is under way in Tennessee
for an inmate accused of killing a
prison administrator before he escaped
the Tennessee Bureau of Investigation
says 44 year old Curtis Ray Watson is
extremely dangerous and warns he may
have left the state yesterday
investigators said they secured warrants
for Watson on charges of first degree
murder aggravated burglary and
aggravated sexual battery
Omar Villafranca is here Omar do
authorities have any idea where Watson
may be short answer at no and Curtis ray
Watson has now been on the run for three
days the Tennessee Bureau of
Investigation has issued a statewide
blue alert which is used when the
suspects kill or seriously injure
officers in the line of duty he escaped
from a prison about an hour north of
Memphis but officials warned he could be
anywhere
this man is considered extremely
dangerous and we need to find him
newly released surveillance images show
Curtis ray Watson the day he escaped
from West Tennessee State Penitentiary
another photo shows what he would have
been wearing jeans and a blue Department
of Corrections shirt troopers have set
up checkpoints for cars on roads leading
to and from the prison and are searching
homes in the area Watson has been in
prison since 2012 serving a 15-year
prison sentence for an aggravated
kidnapping conviction he was previously
convicted of aggravated child abuse
Watson worked in the rural Tennessee
prison as a farm laborer
officials say he escaped on a tractor
and abandoned it about a mile away
Watson is suspected of murdering 64
year-old corrections administrator
Deborah Johnson in her home on prison
grounds the morning he escaped she had
worked for the Department of Corrections
for 38 years
everything about Deborah exemplified
professionalism and her care for both
the people she worked for worked with
and the inmates that she served on a
daily basis we the Tennessee Bureau of
Investigation released two of Watson's
previous mug shots in case he has
altered his facial hair and images of
Watson's tattoos in hopes someone will
be able to identify him
the reward for information leading to
Watson's capture is now more than 52,000
dollars in the TBI has actually received
more than 75 tips that could put them
somewhere in Tennessee or somewhere in
another state but at this point they do
not know where he goes bad I mean to
hear about that administrators that long
and you have to wonder how an inmate
escapes on that tractor Omar it's
somebody had to have seen something
right yeah all right thanks